[Music]
everyone has had a collective breakdown
when we saw that the new record Ralph's
movie has all Disney Princesses
interacting with each other who wouldn't
want to see a modern version of our
faves but stay tuned because many fans
seem to think that the movie actually
totally ruined it for a couple of them
don't forget to hit that notification
valve to never miss another video and be
sure to check out our community section
for even more fun now let's check out
the differences between the original
Disney Princesses and the record Ralph
Burton Rapunzel let's start with the
princess that's still pretty much the
same well except for one thing Rapunzel
still has her green eyes a bright look
and a gorgeous pink dress we're not sure
why but record Rob's version of Rapunzel
still has long hair we're pretty sure
that hair doesn't grow that fast and
there's no way she'd be able to get it
to the same length as before most
importantly why would she do that
anyways Rapunzel even asks Penelope if
she has magic hair you have magic hair
now but didn't her magical hair lose all
the power when it was cut all she got
left was her healing tears but since
that wasn't her main power of the movie
wreck-it Ralph decided to throw all
logic out of the window and pull out the
Rapunzel that was still stuck in the
tower if you look at her eyes you'll
also notice that the record raft version
isn't a vivid green as we might know her
from the actual movie Rapunzel's eyes
used to be as green as pascal's but if
you look at past scale in the
backgrounds on the right from Belle
you'll see that his shade of green
definitely changed Belle so let's have a
look at Belle
since she's standing right next to
Rapunzel when the princess interrogated
vanellope on what makes her a princess
how meta anyways the wreck-it Ralph
version of Belle might definitely feel
different but that's only because it's
been more than 25 years since Beauty and
the Beast first came out the animators
at the time were very limited with what
they could do when it came to bringing
Disney princesses to life but wreck-it
Ralph did that for Belle you can still
see her signature hair very clearly
except now it's even more detailed the
only thing that stands out as majorly
different are her ears in
but that's what happens when you enter
the modern world of animation because of
that you'll notice that her eyes are a
lot bigger in wreckit-ralph and your
eyebrows are way longer the original
Bell also had a wider gap between her
nose and her lips but again these are
just minor differences that are a result
of modern animation either way bow looks
awesome and it's absolutely amazing to
see her again and interacting with her
fellow princesses Cinderella
speaking of old-school animation
Cinderella looks almost unrecognizable
especially up close if it wasn't for her
signature items like her dress and her
hair she could be just about anyone
although record Rob's version of
Cinderella still features the choker
necklace the gorgeous blue dress and the
blue headpiece recognized version is
much tamer we also see her wearing
gigantic sparkly earrings that
definitely look slightly different on
the original Cinderella but if you
consider the fact that the original
Cinderella movie came out in 1950 it
still did an amazing job at creating
something truly iconic seriously what
would we do without Cinderella
although record Ralph's version
definitely puts an interesting spin on
it it's exactly what Cinderella should
look like as a modern-day princess but
what's actually totally different on the
modern Cinderella is her hair although
it's clear that the original
Cinderella's hair would be really hard
to pull off seeing her with straight
bangs just feels weird
not to mention you can totally see
almost every individual piece of hair
which is pretty impressive compare that
to the original Cinderella's hair and
you can definitely see the difference
Snow White we all know that Snow White
is the og aka the first Disney Princess
featured on a full-length movie which is
pretty impressive this also means that
Snow White is pretty old
like 1937 old but isn't it pretty
impressive how Snow White's modern
animated version managed to look exactly
like her old self
of course this version of Snow White has
much more vivid colors but everything
else looks pretty on point
the wreck-it Ralph team even brought to
life her iconic hair which was
absolutely beautifully recreated and
what's even more amazing about this Snow
White is that wreck-it Ralph decided to
have her sing the original voice of Snow
White was
Triana casalotti who wasn't even
credited for the movie rumors state that
her voice was so unique to Disney locked
her in a contract and she was never able
to work on any other movie again the
record Ralph's voice might not be
Adriana but it does pay her a fantastic
tribute after all it's only fair to show
Snow White's unique voice as much as
possible and hey even though Adriana
unfortunately passed away wreck-it Ralph
broke Adriana's contract rules with
Disney and featured a version of
Adriana's beautiful voice
Aurora okay this is pretty interesting
because there are a couple of different
versions of Aurora out there one is the
franchise version and the other is the
original the original because it was
released in 1959 was very simple
graphics and isn't exactly detailed but
Aurora also reappeared in the franchise
version the original had a signature
blue dress and the franchise version had
a pink dress
it looks like the wreckit-ralph version
decided to take on the franchise Aurora
so naturally she'll have the pink dress
but what's interesting about the modern
version is also the fact that her hair
is slightly different have you noticed
the French Birol is set in the opposite
direction than the front twirl in both
older versions other than that wreck-it
Ralph did a pretty awesome job with
representing Aurora did you notice she
was actually sound asleep in the
beginning set and didn't really appear
much after well we all know the real
Aurora would have been wide awake unless
this one's just taken a casual nap to be
honest being a Disney Princess must be
hard work so she definitely deserves a
nap Ariel Ariel briefly appears in the
trailer but it's enough to discuss some
similarities and differences between
this Ariel and the original much like
other princesses we've mentioned so far
The Little Mermaid came out a while back
which means the animation still weren't
as crisp and smooth but it looks like
wreckit-ralph definitely took it one
step further you can see Ariel in the
beginning scene in the back and there's
one thing that stands out more than
anything else it's her red hair it
definitely looks way brighter than it is
in the original movie and of course
slightly longer too but her actions are
pretty bizarre it's windows air
spend a lot of time on her hair why is
she brushing it like she's Rapunzel it
definitely doesn't suit her
but then again maybe there's something
about Ariel we don't really know but
despite the differences wreckit-ralph
made sure that all the details are there
can you see her shiny earrings it's
pretty amazing that they were able to
capture that detail from so far away
unfortunately we don't get to see Ariel
for longer unless you count her long red
hair next to Elsa's who's demonstrating
her powers show off Jasmine now here's
someone that definitely changed a lot
you can first see Jasmine's floating on
the magic carpet and later again when
she gets ready to strike Penelope with
the genie bottle seriously these modern
princesses are savage AF jasmine has
been getting a lot of love from wreck-it
Ralph fans and we have to admit that she
does indeed look good but she's also
quite different of course her clothes
are the same who wouldn't recognize the
iconic Jasmine clothes no one can rock
my blue the way Jasmine does but have
you noticed that her face definitely
looks different all Disney Princesses
seem to have gotten bigger eyes but in
Jasmine's face her face also became
rounder the original jasmine has a
slightly more defined chin but
wreckit-ralph version is as round as her
face her nose also seems to stand out
more especially since we only got the
very basic version of it in the original
you can actually see it stand out way
more than expected when she gets into
her pose ready to strike Penelope but
the fans are right she still looks
absolutely gorgeous and let's be honest
we'll always be jealous of her hair
Merida and now let's move on to one of
the most controversial ones out of the
10 Disney Princesses were showing you
today many have complained that record
Ralph made everyone's favorite feminists
Disney Princess way too similar to
everyone else
after all the beauty of Merida was that
she stood out from her hair right down
to her mission in life the wreck-it
Ralph changed her hair to a slightly
more Airy OS color gave her bigger eyes
thinner waist and the very typical
Disney princess look but hey she's still
holding her crossbow and she was ready
to fire it at Penelope so
no she's still fierce we also love the
moment where she totally disapproved
Snow White's random singing just look at
that shade our girl was totally over it
people are also laughing at the fact
that she looks totally annoyed at the
entire thing which is nothing like the
always positive Merida we know look at
her she was ready to leave the whole
thing and be over with it while the
other princesses were still enjoying
their moment we feel you Merida we
really do Mulan one of the best moments
from the trailer comes from the moment
vanellope appears in the Disney princess
room you can catch it for a split second
but move on actually lunges herself in
the air with a high kick we're telling
you these princesses are serious when it
comes to protecting themselves many
people seem to have missed Mulan in the
trailer but she's definitely there you
can also see her again with other Disney
Princesses and she looks absolutely
gorgeous her appearance was definitely
praised by those who did notice her
although we have to be honest the actual
Mulan probably wouldn't be that quiet
we really hope wreck-it Ralph will give
her some justice with a few lines in the
movie Mulan does look like the happiest
of them all to be there and she's
definitely enjoying the moment in our
ideal world her in Pocahontas would have
a battle so we can finally see who's
actually the strongest out of them -
judging by that high kick this would be
an easy win for Mulan it's also been
argued that Mulan shouldn't be in the
movie anyways since she isn't an
official Disney Princess but she's
definitely a princess in our books
Pocahontas say what at 3d Pocahontas
it's all we ever wanted it's totally
weird seeing a modern version of one of
our favorite Disney Princesses she looks
totally awesome and absolutely fearless
but why is Cinderella doing Pocahontas
his hair and why is Pocahontas enjoying
it like she's in some kind of spa you
think wreck-it Ralph would give her some
kind of characteristics but nope she
looks pretty regular even when she's
ready to swipe vanellope off the face of
the earth people have had mixed
reactions about Pocahontas because
wreck-it Ralph also seemed to have
changed her complexion she practically
looks like every other Disney Princess
next to her though her complexion in the
movie definitely has a much darker tone
and again they made her eyes look
ginormous
but hey at least her hair still flows
for no reason at all
did you notice it's blowing in the wind
even though there's no wind at all and
she still looks like she could kick some
serious butt what do you think of
Pocahontas his new look do you think
wreckit-ralph had a good reason for
making her skin lighter but we did love
seeing her interacts with other
princesses Disney Princesses are still
popular among audiences of all ages and
yet they also have endured their share
of criticism their United appearance in
Ralph breaks the internet prepares
audiences for an unforgettable comeback
watch until number one to see why we can
expect to finally see feminist
princesses if this is your first time
visiting the things don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up here's hidden messages
from Disney's princesses in wreck-it
Ralph to makes fun of Disney Princess
model what does it mean to be a Disney
Princess this is definitely a question
raised by Ralph breaks the internet
trailer when Disney Princesses question
whether or not vanellope qualifies as
one of them a BBC 2012 article questions
the lessons young girls can learn from
Disney Princesses revealing an important
hidden message overall Disney royalty
can teach us a lot about perseverance
and determination as each one had to
overcome a difficult set of obstacles
earlier princesses such as Cinderella
Aurora and Snow White have been
especially criticized for being too
delicately depicted the article also
brings up a great line that really
emphasizes how tropes and models for
Disney Princesses have been forced upon
Disney Princesses the same is that
Cinderella never asked for a prince she
asked for a day off and a dress it seems
that no matter what princesses want
whether it be a chance to live on land
save a parent or wake up from a cruise
the early busy model required this all
to be accomplished according to a
problematic and demeaning set of
standards Rapunzel's self-awareness and
pointing out this model and its
ridiculousness promises that grout
breaks the internet will continue in the
footsteps of frozen Moana and brave in
showing us an alternative model internet
antidotes one comments that Rapunzel
makes when she's confronted with
Penelope is asking if she's ever been
poisoned the implication of this
question is that a princess might be
defined by the fact that she has
overcome poisoning though the
fact is pointed out as part of a list
that shows that Disney is willing to
laugh at itself for its past blunders
when it comes to representation of women
it also causes us to think about how far
we've come
Snow White in the Seven Dwarfs came out
in 1937 at the time seeing a woman
kissed 12 men as they left for work was
cute and charming having her downfall be
the manipulation at the hands of a
stranger who caused her to eat a
poisoned Apple was horrific but in an
entertaining way
now these concepts would provoke so much
criticism that would hinder a movie
success the hidden message is that the
internet informed us about problems
faced by people whose voices have not
always been heard
having the princesses as part of an
internet platform actually points out
that the Internet itself has contributed
to how we have become more aware of
harmful treatment of women and has now
resulted in a lower tolerance to making
fun of others oppression all good things
passive to active as soon as Penelope
appears in a room filled with Disney
Princesses their response is hilarious
as it shows the princesses and an
uncharacteristically defensive light
instead of being victims of their
circumstances and fulfilling the role of
damsels in distress' they brandished
weapons to defend themselves against the
potential threat we might expect that a
roomful of Disney Princesses would adopt
a much more passive attitude in light of
danger it would call for help this is
not the case in the scene from there
Ralph breaks the internet trailer
Jasmine uses her magic lamp as a weapon
Pocahontas has her wooden staff ready
and Cinderella smashes her glass slipper
to use it as a sharp tool to protect
yourself the princesses from the past
have always waited for some kind of
action or event to happen but in the
trailer we see these same princesses
preparing to defend themselves and each
other this is definitely refreshing to
see that princesses are no longer
relying on men for their rescue that are
following new princesses like Elsa and
Anna Moana and Merida for demonstrating
strength without meeting the man's
validation what was your reaction to
these self-sufficient princesses and
their reaction to a younger and less
conventional princess a man to save the
day
Ralph breaks the Internet is getting a
lot of attention because of the movie's
obvious self-awareness and willingness
to poke fun at itself it's easy to
criticize the movies choices and it's
even
easier to criticize Disney because of
its questionable decisions it seems that
the rugged Ralph's sequel has thought
ahead and is instead using this
crossover opportunity as a way to
anticipate these critical remarks while
vanellope is horrified by the
classification system that the Disney
Princesses use she ultimately find
common ground different disses asked
Penelope a series of worries and
questions to which she becomes concerned
even asking if she needs to call the
police
Penelope is showing the audience that
Disney is aware that women should never
have to endure the terrible treatment
that they have suffered it also suggests
that putting up with this treatment is
not an ideal princess-like way to behave
in the end the princesses accept
Penelope as one of their own when she
admits that she has also experienced
that people assume that a man is needed
to save the day this alludes to the
first movie and vanilla peas reluctance
when she first meets Ralph however it
also proves that Disney continues to
follow stereotypical tropes for women in
movies but now they are aware and ready
to poke fun at themselves most of the
original voice actors are back the
Disney Princess teen is definitely also
used as a way to draw in an older
audience as it creates a sense of
nostalgia not only is this a first for
all the Disney Princesses to appear on
screen together but they are also all
performed by the original voice actors
the familiarity of the voices definitely
adds to surreal facts to the fact that
the princesses we grew up with are all
in the same room together as awesome and
exciting as this may be it causes us to
have to point out a darker truth behind
Disney's classic princess voice Snow
White
Snow White's voice in 1937 when the
movie came out is unofficially credited
to actress adriana caselotti rumor is
that Disney owned the rights to Castle
Ali's unforgettable voice and prevented
her from pursuing a career after Snow
White it has been said that Disney
claimed he wanted to keep Snow White's
identity a mystery so that the fictional
character would always remain as she is
it's terrible to think that casalotti
never achieves the type of recognition
her talent deserved since 2011 actress
Katie Vaughn Hill has been the only
voice responsible to Snow White nothing
better to do can we just take a second
to ask about where exactly vanilla
people
these princesses it seems that they are
in some kind of dressing room and when
they first appear on screen they don't
seem to be occupied by anything the
princesses embody their denie ourselves
as they sit around in full ball gowns it
seems this is the room they hang out in
between their group performances which
is where we see them for the first time
in the trailer valise reading and
Rapunzel is writing other than that it's
unclear what the other princesses are
busy doing to pass the time Jasmine
those sitting on a magic carpet is
simply looking at a flower
much like Tiana who is just looking out
the window and Snow White who is calling
a bird to her outstretched fingers
doesn't it seem strange that these
princesses supposedly known for their
role in their kingdoms are spending
their downtime grooming one another and
in deep contemplation this might be
another way for Disney to show that it
hasn't represented femininity in all of
its aspects in past movies but it still
feels like a missed opportunity these
princesses could have been showing off
the diversity of their strengths and
talents is vanellope at Disney Princess
Penelope's first reaction to arriving at
her destination is disgust as she says
princesses and cartoon characters barf
vanellope takes ownership of her status
as a princess and this brings up a great
hidden message about Penelope's
contribution to the Disney Princess
legacy when Ralf first meets vanilla P
in wreck-it Ralph she's a princess and
sugar rush vying for a spot on the
racing leaderboard the only problem is
is that she doesn't fit in because she's
a glitch and this subjects her to
ridicule ultimately Manila P learns to
embrace what makes her different and
unique and refuses to give it up this
really does embody a Disney Princesses
spirit as she's determined resilient and
compassionate she also has faults that
she embraces as what makes her occur
there are some significant differences
though Penelope is not looking for any
type of romantic love nor is she ready
to do so as she's much younger than the
typical Disney Princess
what's more she rejects the stylistic
tropes that princesses like Cinderella
aspire to she opts for a green hoodie
over a pink hoop skirt a dress
overall Penelope is a welcome addition
to the princess lineup especially since
she's a catalyst for causing the
traditional princesses to question their
problematic history
Disney owns everything aside from owning
up to its sexist past and tendency for
gender stereotyping Ralph breaks the
internet uses its trailer to demonstrate
its wide cultural reach Disney doesn't
have the same usual copyright
constraints that other movies have to
deal with and they're willing to use
that completely to their advantage
there's no limit to the movie references
Disney can make since they have bought
and acquired such a wide array of
production companies and Studios in one
frame from the trailer the viewers are
confronted just how much Disney has to
flaunt as we can clearly see Mickey the
Millennium Falcon a TIE fighter the
Dutch star betamax Ironman Kermit the
Frog Dumbo r2d2 the house from up and
more these are just visible from one
shot in the movie trailer which only
alludes to the marketing potential in a
crossover movie like Ralph breaks the
Internet
Disney itself is relying on its capacity
to band fans of multiple genres and
generations together to accomplish the
exact same goal of breaking the Internet
after all the movies Pixar quality is
not meant to stand in its way of
reaching Disney level successes at the
box office and it seems like there are
no length Disney won't go to to reach
these Heights Marriott cover up Disney's
acquiring at Pixar has not been a
seamless one especially when it comes to
the criticism surrounding Disney's
appropriation of brave Merida was hailed
as a female protagonist that did not
have time to worry about romantic love
and raced her much more realistic figure
and was not confined by gender
stereotypes when Disney then proceeded
to alter her waist measurements in
preparation for her entrance in the
Disney Princess lineup they received a
lot of criticism for their choices
including Merida and the Disney Princess
scene and Ralph breaks the Internet
definitely demonstrates that Disney is
embracing this heroine as one of their
own but they don't seem ready to put in
center stage just yet she's not seen in
the first shot of the princesses in
their dressing room and remains very
much in the background in other scenes
maybe this is Disney's way of trying to
keep the spotlight off her which will
help keep them free of unwanted negative
feedback about how they've represented
her character twitter users were
especially enraged by Milan's missing
appearance in the movie
as well as aerials it has been confirmed
however that all three princesses will
stand along their cohorts in the movie
feminine undertones not only is Disney
trying to take accountability for its
sexist stereotyping in the past it seems
to also be promoting a feminist message
while Arielle literally gave up her
voice for her chance at love and human
legs
Aurora couldn't provide consent to true
love while in a deep sleep these
messages continue to be reasons for
audiences to question the message and
proceed and Disney Princesses have sets
for their impressionable audiences the
much-anticipated and highly popular
scene of Disney Princesses together on
screen for the first time was also
monumental for the decision to
demonstrate self-awareness at how
troubling some of these storylines are
especially in a contemporary context
Penelope is the young heroine who points
this out while bonding over the
assumption that men are required to save
the day this potential for female
bonding in sets of a feminist undertone
for the movie that parallels the
strength of Marvel Avengers superheroes
to the wisdom strength and resilience of
Disney Princesses who knows what stories
could be possible when the two are
finally put on equal footing it also
suggests that a raft breaks the internet
will be a departure from an outdated
misogynistic character model anyone can
see that Merida of dunbroch sticks out
like a sore thumb when standing next to
the other Disney Princesses wreck-it
Ralph too is scheduled to hit the big
screen in late 2018 and judging from
this trailer it looks like the
princesses have it out for the first
Pixar princess stick around to find out
why Merida is breaking all of the rules
don't forget to subscribe to the things
if you love staying up to date with the
latest Disney news give us a big thumbs
up and more awesome videos will come
your way now let's find out why Princess
Merida is getting roasted left right and
center
just six years before the movie brave
came out in theaters Walt Disney Studios
decided to join forces with Pixar the
house of mouse bought Pixar and has been
working alongside it ever since Merida
became an official Disney Princess back
in 2013 however she isn't like the rest
of the women in the group did you catch
the latest record Ralph - trailer if so
you probably notice how the Disney
Princesses were throwing some shade
Merida sway while she might not have
done anything to warrant this her
differences make her easy to pick on as
soon as the brave star begins to speak
the princesses around her stare at her
in disbelief
vanellope von schweetz his jaw
practically hits the floor and princes
on a whispers she's from the other
studio while looking apologetic while
Merida might not get the joke it's quite
obvious that she's having some issues
with communicating her incredibly thick
accent makes it impossible to understand
her pure mace I don't know why which is
why many of us hope that she'll have
some subtitles in the movie did any of
you understand what she said the first
time around if so let us know what you
think you heard in the comments and
we'll reveal what she really said at the
end of this video despite the fact that
Merida is a much-loved Disney Princess
she's also the first Disney Pixar
princess to join the group this makes
her different than the other girls in
the dressing room top that off with her
brute ways and it's easy to see that the
Disney Princesses just don't know what
to do with her on top of all this the
Disney Princesses might be a little
jealous of her background after all hers
is the opposite of what they had to go
through by now we've seen the same tire
plot over and over again girl feels lost
girl meets boy boy saves girl and they
live happily ever after if you're
anything like us you're a little sick
and tired of these types of storylines
for centuries this is the plot
production Disney has been made to
follow
however after 2012's brave came out the
enchanted era ended with Pixar in its
back pockets at only 15 years old Merida
was being talked into marrying her
betrothed however the last thing she
wanted to do was get married nope our
girl Merida wanted to be as free as a
bird the fact that Merida is the first
Disney princess who doesn't have aha
is a major deal it's obvious that Disney
is trying to shake up the norm by giving
us something other than a love story to
watch this may be a little frustrating
for the other Disney Princesses as they
remain to marry from very early on look
at Snow White she got married at 14
years old no wonder she's bitter for the
time being it looks like Merida might
stay single for the rest of her life and
there's nothing wrong with that
on another note Merida also has
something that the other princesses
crave a huge family have you ever
wondered why Disney Princesses tend to
be raised by single fathers or evil
stepmothers well we have to so allow us
to clear this up for you out of the
eleven Disney Princesses on record only
three of them have mothers of their own
Mulan Tiana and Merida have managed to
be raised by women which might have
given them the strength they needed to
follow their hearts the real reason for
this reoccurring theme however has
everything to do with Walt Disney and
nothing to do with his princesses you
see Walt Disney was traumatized by his
own mother's passing which prompted in
the past his pain on to his characters
obviously things needed to change which
is why many of the new princesses are
starting to have both their parents
present the fact that Merida had both
her mother her father and a bunch of
siblings is quite astonishing though
actually it's a first as a result of
this some Disney Princesses might feel
the need to roast their Scottish member
after all she doesn't know what growing
up alone feels like don't think this is
a good enough reason to roast someone
wait until you hear the last one on this
list when you think about Disney movies
you think about singing and dancing
right well we hope you didn't get your
hopes up when watching brave because
singing and dancing don't exist in this
movie it is common knowledge that every
single Disney Princess has the voice of
an angel
however Merida never let her pipe shine
bright like a diamond this leads us to
believe that she's either a terrible
singer or she just doesn't like spending
her time bursting into song we're under
the impression that the Disney
Princesses like to roast Merida for her
awful voice in the end these ladies
probably enjoy sharing a song or two
behind the scenes and she probably gets
left out 100% of the time so why is it
that Merida refrains from singing a
single notes for the entirety of brave
the Reese
behind this it's quite simple the girl
doesn't want to sing disney has been
changing the rules for quite some time
now but having a song this movie is
quite absurd were you disappointed when
you found out that singing and dancing
had no place in brave if so or just know
that you're not the only one
so the moment we've all been waiting for
is here we're finally going to find out
what merit is said in the record Ralph -
trailer the Disney Pixar princess says
the following
I gave me mummy a cake she turned into a
big bear my old yen tried to do her in
and if that's not a pure mess I don't
know what is after seeing the look on
Penelope's face they want to tells her
that they can't understand her either
and onna times in that she's from
another studio this Disney Pixar joke is
definitely hilarious Meredith's thick
Scottish accent is impossible to
decipher which will make her a hilarious
character and wreck-it Ralph - and who
knows maybe we'll hear her singing for
the first time and get blown away with
so many Disney Princesses to choose from
picking a favorite can seem impossible
if you had to choose one know which one
would it be let us know who your
favorite princess is in the comments and
be sure to tell us what makes her so
special to you it's easy to get caught
up in the hype of seeing our favorite
Disney Princesses interacting with each
other in wreck-it Ralph - however we've
noticed a few disturbing things about
our beloved Merida that fans are less
than happy about we'll take you inside
the controversy and let you choose which
side you're on in the debate don't
forget to subscribe to the things if you
love Disney and hit that notification
bell to never miss another video now
let's check out what's going on with
Merida let's get this out of the way we
love Disney movies there's so much to
like about them and it seems like
they're getting better all the time
Disney has been around for so long that
it's not surprising they have some
regrettable things in their history
especially where women are involved for
a long time the company drew criticisms
because they constantly portrayed their
heroines as hapless and showed some
pretty disturbing relationship dynamics
you know like Belle's
Stockholm Syndrome or that it's okay to
kiss unconscious women on the off chance
they've been poisoned by a witch with
the passage of time and the raising of
voices it finally seen that Disney was
getting the message we
wanted heroines that were ready willing
and able to save themselves instead of
relying on a man to save them and going
even further than that
what about a woman who doesn't have or
even want a man in her life in Disney
movies it seems like all women who fit
that description are always evil as if
having a relationship makes you a better
person and then we heard about the movie
brave directed by Mark Andrews and
Brenda Chapman Chapman drew inspiration
from her relationship with her own
daughter and became the first female to
direct a feature-length film for Pixar
things seem to be looking good and the
movie itself was far from disappointing
the first thing we noticed about Merida
was her appearance and we were thrilled
that she looked so different than many
other heroines she has fiery thick and
unruly hair instead of the perfectly
poised locks of other princesses she
also looks like the teenage girl that
she's supposed to be and is a much more
realistic looking princess than we're
used to seeing instead of focusing on
finding a man Merida is already
betrothed to one and she isn't happy
about it we see her fighting her own
battles wielding powerful weapons and
basically being the princess we all
wanted to see when we were all little
girls it seemed like Disney was finally
getting the message but then things went
south fans hoping to visit the official
brave website were in for an unpleasant
surprise when they encountered a
completely made over Merida Disney took
a character that we adored because of
how strong and well brave she was and
made her look like a totally generic
princess this new look was supposed to
come across as glamorous but that's not
an adjective we would ever use to
describe Merida it seemed like Disney
had taken two steps forward and one step
back with their handling of Merida the
new version looked thinner older and
much less like her normal self people
were deeply unhappy with the change and
were sure to let Disney know they even
started a petition on change.org which
gathered over two hundred thousand
signatures even Brenda Chapman was
furious about the change and we don't
blame her one bit she even went as far
as calling it atrocious according to her
Merida was created to break the mold and
give young girls a
good role model thankfully it seemed
like Disney finally got the message
again and removed the glamorized version
of Merida from the website Disney
released a statement claiming that the
design was intended to be a one-off and
had served its purpose and would now be
removed but of course as we all know
this story doesn't end there one of the
most exciting things about the new
wreck-it Ralph is the fact that we're
gonna get to see the princesses on the
big screen the good news is that Merida
is included with the rest of the cast as
she should be of course but the bad news
is that she doesn't look anything like
the original version you may be willing
to chalk this up to the difference in
animation styles between brave and
wreck-it Ralph - but that just doesn't
completely explain it let's take a look
at Belle Beauty and the Beast came out
decades ago and yet she is completely
recognizable after her makeover same
with Cinderella Aurora and Snow White
and their films came out way before
braid did at this point it's pretty
obvious that the cosmetic differences
between the Merida we met in brave and
the version we see in wreck-it Ralph are
intentional rather than accidental it
looks as if Disney decided to go with
the glamorized version of Merida that
they created instead of the original
version of Merida that was such a
success with fans this just leaves us
wondering why who is this for
Merida was an important character who
arguably paved the way for stronger
Disney Princesses frozen is frequently
praised because Elsa and Anna didn't
rely on men to save them however both
heroines look much more like typical
Disney Princesses than Merida does and
you'll notice they look pretty much the
same in wreck-it Ralph - and when we
watch the trailer for the movie at first
it seemed like Disney was getting it
many of the other princesses seemed to
meet making fun of typical Disney tropes
when trying to determine whether or not
vanellope is a princess the girls even
asked her if people always assume that a
man is gonna save her do people assume
all your problems got solved because a
big strong man showed up it seems like
Disney was trying to laugh at itself and
show that female characters can be
strong but if they truly believe that
then why did they use a glamorized
Merida instead of the original think
about it it can't be - a
pres Penelope who wears a hoodie and
looks very young recognizing the problem
is one thing but to impress us Disney
actually needs to address it many fans
are upset that we're getting a dolled up
version of Merida and consider it to be
an insult towards an awesome character
however others think feeling outraged
over Merida's appearance is making a big
deal about nothing there's definitely no
denying that Merida looks different than
we're used to seeing her but is that a
good thing a bad thing or not really a
thing at all
wreck-it Ralph - managed to break the
internet before the movie even came out
but there are far more details in the
trailer people actually overlooked have
you paid enough attention to Moana to
see this mind-boggling detail don't
forget to hit that notification bell to
never miss another video now let's check
out some details about Moana from
wreck-it Ralph to hanging out with Elsa
and Anna okay we get Bette Moana Elsa
and Anna are all modern princesses so it
would only be fair they stay together
have you spotted them when vanellope
first appeared they were chillin in the
back together Moana was casually resting
on her boat paddle and by the looks of
it they're having a pretty awesome
conversation we really want to know what
they're talking about you can also see
her be chill with Merida and the excited
Rapunzel next to her this version of
Moana is wearing the heart of defeat II
on her neck which is pretty awesome but
we also love that she's dressed in her
typical clothing from the movie but
seriously what are these Disney
Princesses actually talking about they
look like they've known each other for
years and they're immediately able to
become each other's BFFs chilling with
Rapunzel but that's not the end of Moana
we see her again in one of the more
recent stills that managed to break the
entire Internet again Twitter went wild
after Disney released the image of the
Disney princess slumber party we're
still not over the fact that we'll get
to see Disney Princesses casually
hanging out and talked to each other all
in the same room seriously
we're not over it but have you noticed
Moana she's just so chill about the
whole thing
she seems totally smitten with vanellope
heads we can't blame her considering how
cute she is we can't see what she's
wearing in full but from what it looks
like she has an orange top on
considering other princesses have some
sort of lounge where we can imagine
Moana will most likely be wearing either
pants or shorts
seems strange to
in regular clothing but it seems even
stranger that we haven't seen her in a
while and we saw all the other Disney
Princesses you can even see that
Rapunzel looks like she's totally laying
on Moana was this done because they
couldn't figure out what kind of clothes
they want to give to everyone's favorite
island princess we've discussed the
awesome casual clothing Disney
Princesses wear in one of our previous
videos and Moana definitely wasn't shown
enough to come to any conclusions we'll
have to wait until the movie comes out
to see but have you noticed the detail
that left twitter totally shook this
entire record Ralph too has already been
a wild ride and the movie hasn't even
dropped yet but this one detail really
proves a Disney Theory fans had for
years baby Moana have you noticed it
there are several tweets out there that
managed to get viral thanks to the very
first wreck-it Ralph - trailer and
they're all equally as confused with
this scene that so many people managed
to overlook this tiny little detail just
proves that there's way more to unpack
from the trailer than just the scenes
with the Disney Princesses of course
it's totally understandable that people
were so excited about seeing all of our
favorite Disney heroines in the same
room but we totally forgot to focus on
other parts of the trailer the moment is
already becoming a huge meme and many
have turned their tablet screened into
their own version of what the baby is
actually looking at but that's not what
you should be paying attention to did
you notice the baby actually looks
similar to baby Moana from the actual
movie just look at her features the skin
tone the nose the big brown eyes the
short hair it's totally her even the
eyebrows totally matched to the cartoons
character we saw running toward the
ocean and trying to grab the heart of
defeating before it got washed away we
have no idea what the baby Moana will
actually be doing in the record Ralph -
movie or if this in fact is a baby Moana
but you can't deny that the similarities
are too good to be ignored if anything
this proves a very important Disney
theory that has been explored plenty of
times before if you watch our Disney
videos you'll know that we covered the
topic that all Disney movies are somehow
connected with each other
Disney even admitted they've connected
the movies themselves from Alexa ball to
several other small objects you can find
in almost every Disney movie ever made
they really do know how to keep their
fans engaged with the movies so could
this be yet another easter egg Disney
decided to throw in one of their
movies wreckit-ralph 2 is already full
of Disney scenes so maybe this one they
made it's slightly more difficult to
find and difficult to guess why these
characters and objects are there in the
first place we know it wouldn't actually
make sense considering baby Moana was on
the islands and this little baby looks
about the same age but it really does
make you wonder what's up with the
similarities all this version of baby
Mona's missing is Maui a chicken and her
pig and the Easter egg is complete but
is it real or is it just a simple
character recycling will this be the
alternate reality is this the reason we
see Disney Princesses all in the same
room the movie is all about breaking the
internet so who knows maybe they'll
bring us several different alternative
realities we've never even considered
before like Disney Princesses having a
total different role as babies baby
Moana hasn't returned to the second
trailer so perhaps her role isn't as
important as it might seem what do you
think do you have your own theory about
baby Moana in wreck-it Ralph - make sure
to watch the trailer again and give us
your opinion are we just imagining all
of this or is it actually baby Moana how
would that even be possible
our heads are about to explode from all
these questions so make sure to come
debate in the comments we always love to
hear your thoughts wreck-it Ralph 2
comes out November 2018 and you know
we'll be watching and posting new Easter
eggs and theories have you seen the
record Ralph - slumber party photo
we're totally here for Disney Princesses
in their casual outfits stay tuned to
find out the most surprising meta moment
of the slumber party scene don't forget
to hit that notification bell to never
miss another video and be sure to check
out our community section for even more
fun now let's check out Disney
Princesses in casual outfits
mommy aqui she turned on topic beer
didn't I - dear then move on let's start
with Mulan who also is the only princess
that opted out for an on PJ look you
can't really blame her Mulan always did
things her way and it's why she's one of
our favorites even here you can see her
wearing something totally different from
anyone else the slumber party version of
Mulan is rocking and absolutely styling
bomber jacket rolled up jeans and red
high-tops it might seem like a totally
unusual sight but don't forget this
isn't Mulan from the movie anymore this
is the new and improved version that's
clearly keeping up with modern day
fashion all the while still having her
own style
we're totally here for it good job Milan
Anna love is an open door right did you
notice what anna is wearing well apart
from the rolled up sleeve lentil it's
very easy to miss especially since she's
so far away according to the internet
honest shirt actually has a picture of a
sandwich with text that reads finish
each other's but how cool is it that
this tiny detail can actually be seen on
her clothes of course we love the
flannel shirt too and if you check
Twitter you'll find out some secret
hence what these clothes represents we
love Twitter and their theories wait
until you see what they thought of Elsa
Snow White the internet pointed out that
Snow White's outfit represents more than
just some casual PJs her outfit actually
has an apple with the skull yep the same
Apple that actually almost ended her
life how powerful is that
she's totally owning her story of course
a lot of Disney Princesses were in
life-threatening situations but Snow
White's was one of the worst you think
she was scarred for life and wouldn't
dare to even come close to another Apple
but she's totally owning it in this
casual outfit Tiana sure Tiana is hiding
behind her Starbucks drink but fans have
pointed out another important detail
this is the first time were actually
seeing Tiana relax and having her hair
down usually she's always busy working
and this is one of the few times where
we can just see Tiana completely relaxed
and to be honest were totally okay with
that also her natural hair looks
absolutely adorable although we're not
sure Starbucks will actually help Tiana
sleep
these Disney Princesses are staying up
all night what do you think they're
talking about we'd love to know what's
going on but you have to admit it's nice
to see her with her hair down Cinderella
have you seen Cinderella's outfit it's
pretty awesome we love the overall look
but what sets Cinderella apart is her
modern take on her story her PJ's
actually has a pumpkin carriage but pay
attention to what's written on the
carriage it says g2g which stands for
got to go
how very Internet of Disney talked about
being relatable and embracing what she
went through as a kid we can't imagine
Cinderella using slang words or acronyms
like that in real life but who knows
maybe this movie will show us a totally
different side of Disney Princesses well
it kind of already did we never saw any
of this coming wait until you see what
Twitter thinks about that look she's
giving to Elsa do people assume all your
problems got solved because a big strong
man showed up rapunzel Rapunzel zop that
isn't shown in full but it's very
interesting to see her in the same
colors as her movie dress you can't see
it in a lot of detail but she's wearing
a cozy pink sweater we've never seen
Rapunzel and anything other than a dress
so this is quite a surprising move but
we do love that she actually stayed in
pink it's after all one of her most
iconic colors and we already know her
long hair is back for this movie do you
think all the other princesses had to
help her move her hair out of the way
sounds messy Moana out of all Disney
Princesses it looks like Moana is the
one that's staying true to her movie
outfit well sort of you obviously can't
see her outfit but you can see her
orange tank top the orange color
definitely suits her and we can't wait
to see the outfit in full do you think
she'll be wearing a skirt jeans or
leggings we're leaning towards some cozy
colorful leggings to match the top but
you never know what they'll do come on
Disney hurry up we want to see what
Moana will look like Elsa and last but
not least there's Elsa she definitely
has one of the most meta outfits
ever and we're totally here for it do
you see the text on her PJ's it says
just let it go which is an obvious
reference to her iconic song it's hard
to let go when that song just keeps
popping back into our heads
just won't go away but you have to be
honest this is the best outfit ever her
drink looks perfect too and we love the
look she's giving to Cinderella people
on Twitter are already speculating that
there's something going on between these
two and let's be honest we'd love to see
Disney make that happen
wreck-it Ralph too comes in theatres on
the 21st of November 2018 will you be
watching you know we will just so we can
see how these casual outfits will look
on other princesses
speaking of Merida Belle Aurora and
Jasmine weren't featured in the slumber
party photo but we're pretty sure
they're still in the movie we can't wait
to see what they'll be wearing during
the slumber party well if they're
actually in it of course and that's it
for our video thanks for watching see
you next time
[Music]